Okay, yeah.
Yeah,
so and the message earlier that he won't
be able to attend. That's not right. Yeah.
Every little day, yeah.
So,
we were just talking about a bit of the...
on the progress that we have.
So as of now,
Mhm.
I'm already done with everything on my
end, even the testing.
Mhm.
But I will start doing the Sprint 3
planning.
Mm.
So...
We'll be able to maybe finish that
tomorrow. I'll be able to finish that.
And how about you? How is on your end?
Mhm.
As I updated last night,
it's like I did finish 2 pages.
Yep.
And I think I'm going to do,
not do actually,
I did 3 pages and I'll try to do two or
three more by tonight. And yeah,
by Wednesday, like tomorrow,
I don't think so I can do anything.
But on Wednesday,
I'll try to finish as much as I can
Mhm.
because yeah,
that's the like off day I have.
So I'll try to finish as much as I can.
Yeah, that's the update from my end.
Yeah, at least now we're progressing.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
But Sprint 3 is already like starting
today, I think,
Yeah.
but at least we're not that much backlog.
Mm.
Not last week,
so I think we'll be able to be on this on
schedule after this one.
Yeah.
Yeah, so as of now,
that's I think that's everything.
After that,
you can like do the testing or if you're
a bit busy on that after you finish all
of your tasks, I can help you. You just,
Mm.
you can just, you know,
hit me up and I'll be able to help you
Mm.
with the testing.
Okay,
so I will try to finish as much as
Yeah.
designer. I can buy these Wednesday.
And then on maybe Thursday,
Yeah.
I'll give you a knock that what to do
with the testing or something,
or maybe like next Monday.
Yeah, alright, no worries about that.
because like Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
I'm not available at all. After that,
Yeah, no worries, Stephen.
like, yeah.
Or either Thursday or next Monday,
like any of these two days.
Yeah, because.
And remember that I think next week,
what week are we are we week?
Seven as of now.
We are, no, this is week 8. Yeah,
today is week 8.
OK.
Yeah,
so I just want to give you a heads up
that next week we have the progress
report. Yes.
Yeah, progress report.
I don't know how I missed the first one.
I mailed him,
but he didn't reply to me back.
But then I submitted it. There's no,
I don't think so I'm going to get marked
over that thing.
Mhm.
But there's like no response from him yet.
So I don't know actually.
Yeah.
Yeah, no worries.
At least I just reminded you,
so just to make sure that we can help.
Yeah, yeah, no,
I'll submit the second one for sure. Like,
I'm not gonna forget the second one, yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, alright. No worries.
Maybe next week, Wednesday, Saturday,
the talking points for this one and the
last meeting that we have,
I'll just send like a...
Mhm.
What's that meeting minutes of the
meeting? So, yeah,
Mm-hmm.
'cause I think we really need to add
those also.
On the progress report.
So I'll just send it to all of us have
like the same.
An answer to that one, those answers, so..
.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll do that one.
Okay, I think that's all for today.
Right.
Yeah, I think that's all for the day. Yep.
Okay, then bye. Have a good day.
Alright, thank you. Bye. See ya.
See ya.